good day to everyone joining us
and welcome to today's visio farm
webinar
my name is brendan hopkinson i'll be
your moderator for this lecture
today we have one of our experts in
digital pathology janita omanovic is our
clinical development engineer
and data lead she has been here at vizio
farm for five years and helps develop
our ceivd apps
and data sourcing and data management
she specializes in external projects and
collaborations within the clinical realm
and today she will be discussing
standardization in clinical digital
pathology
using a ki 67 case i'm excited to get
started so it is my pleasure to welcome
junita omanovic
and i'll let you take it from here so
please begin whenever you're ready
thank you for the introduction brandon
and hello to everyone joining in on this
webinar
so today's topic is standardization
using clinical digital pathology which
is a topic very close at heart to us
here in virginia farm
there are many areas where digital
pathology can offer standardization
but we will be zooming in on the
infamous ki67 case for breast cancer
so for today's talk we will look into
the biomarker ki67
and the issues surrounding the use of
ki-67 in clinical practice
then we will talk a bit about different
approaches to digital pathology and we
will showcase the c
ibd marked algorithms we have developed
for care67
we will look at the scientific validity
behind these algorithms and finally we
will also look at what ai and deep
learning developments
we have before we dive into the ks67
case i just want to start off by giving
you a short introduction to visual farm
and our mission
so we're obviously a company that
focuses on digital pathology
and our goal is simply to give
pathologists and researchers
around the world the best and latest
technology so that they can get the most
out of their tissue data
now obtaining tissue data is a somewhat
cumbersome process
as partly illustrated on this slide
there's a lot of steps that needs to be
conducted for example excisioning
fixation
sectioning staining assessment and so on
so when you combine the facts that
today's laboratory workflows are still
rather manual
we have an increase in cancer cases and
a demand for more pathologists
you see that the pathology laboratory
face several limitations
and some of these limitations could end
up causing
an accumulation of assessment errors and
this is where
digital image analysis comes into play
so what we believe is that with digital
imaging analysis
we're able to alleviate some of the
limits experienced in the pathology
laboratories
we can do complex data analysis ensure
optimal digital workflows
and maybe most importantly provide
standardized validated and precise
data and results and that's exactly what
we will be focusing on today
so let's turn our attention to the
care67 case and in particular within
breast cancer
so kr67 is a nuclear proliferation
biomarker and it has multiple potential
roles in different cancers
both as a prognostic but also predictive
marker
but there are some controversies
surrounding ki-67
when we are talking about ks67 we have
this one figure we always like to show
the figure is from a study conducted by
rasmussrui and colleagues from nordic uc
back in 2013. they wanted to examine how
different pathology laboratories score
k67 stain tissues
for this study they created a tissue
migraine with 20 breast tumor cores that
had a varied k67 expression
the tma slide was stained with care 67
scanned and
sent for assessment at 126 pathologists
the figure here shows the manually
assessed care 67 proliferation index for
each of the 20 tumor cores on the tma
slide
what we see is that there is a huge
variability in the reported results
so we see that scores can even range
from negative to highly positive
look at core 10 for example some say the
proliferation index is just above zero
while others report a proliferation
index as high
as 50 and something what this shows is
that a patient might be assessed as one
thing
in one hospital but another thing in
another hospital
this can naturally and unfortunately
have an infect
under patient management
now you might say well this study is
from 2013
it's many years ago now surely things
have changed
but when you look at more recent
literature on kl67
you will see that the number one issue
still addressed
is the inter and intra variability when
assessing kl67
here i just showed a few example
articles from 2017
up till today and as you can see all of
them
were touching upon the inter and
intra-observability
that you're observed with ki-67
now one question we asked ourselves when
we first realized how difficult it is to
assess the k67 proliferation index
was if image analysis could be a way
forward to obtain a standardized and
reproducible method for care 67
assessment
we were so lucky that we got our hands
on the tma course from the study
conducted by reisman sure and colleagues
and we could therefore analyze the tumor
course with our care 67 algorithm to the
left you can see the original manual
assessments and then we have plotted the
image analysis results as a green dot on
top of the boxplots
on the figure to the right we have
plotted the median manual scores and the
image analysis results
and interestingly we see a very high
correlation between these two variables
and thus also a potential for image
analysis to be used as a standardized
method for care 67 assessment and
also a way to overcome the controversy
around the
intra and intro variability
but the story doesn't end there another
controversy around ki67 is what scoring
method to use
for several years it has been discussed
whether global scoring or hotspot
scoring is the way forward
and as of today a recommendation for
what scoring method to use
is lacking in international guidelines
and thus
different countries have different
national guidelines
some recommend hot spots some don't
as we will see later we have developed
image analysis tools that can both
accommodate global care 67 scoring but
also
hotspot scoring before we move to
looking at the image analysis tools we
have i would like to spend just a few
minutes on the evolution
in approaches to digital pathology
so digital pathology is still a
relatively young
field but nonetheless a lot has happened
and especially the introduction of ai
and deep learning in digital pathology
has really
as in many other fields been a game
changer
we have been in the business for quite
many years and we have looked back to
the early start of digital pathology and
up until now
and we have been able to identify three
principal approaches to digital
pathologies
we can also say three workflow paradigms
so the first and most basic of the
workflows is depicted on this slide
the workflow basically consists of three
steps
first the pathologist needs to annotate
the relevant regions to be analyzed
then an algorithm is run within this
region and finally the pathologist can
review the result
as you might have guessed annotation of
regions is a very time consuming task
and can also be quite a subjective task
where different pathologists
end up annotating different regions
so with this workflow we don't exactly
end up with a fully standardized and
reproducible approach
now in the second workflow the image
analysis is run on the whole slide and
the pathologist
afterwards confines the results to the
relevant regions
and makes you can say the image analysis
fit the purpose
so again quite a lot of manual
interaction is necessary
and this is for example to ensure that
stromal cells are not counted
this costs time and might also lack
in reproducibility and standardization
so in the third workflow it's all about
automation
in this workflow we are automatically
identifying the relevant regions to
assess
we run the image analysis in these
reasons and all the pathologist
needs to do is qc the result and sign
off on the case
so in this workflow we are saving the
pathologist time and we are providing
a standardized and reproducible test
result
these three workflows that i have shown
are all available on the market today
but we see a shift in that more and more
people are out for a more
automated workflow like the one shown
here
in our opinion this is also the workflow
that is of most value and this is why we
have for many years been focusing on
how we can automate the assessment
process as much as possible
and this leads us to our next slide
so here we have shown the full panel of
ki67 solutions that we offer for breast
cancer
we will start by going through the
solutions shown in blue
these are all ce marked for enriched
diagnostics used in europe
as you can see the full workflow is
stepwise and requires some tumor
detection
biomarker quantification and finally
hurtful detection if desired
each solution works on its own but it
can also be combined to get a fully
automated ki-67 assessment
so if we look at the first step towards
automation you will see that we offer
two solutions for tumor detection
the pck tumor detection provides a
general tumor outline
whereas the invasive tumor detection
solution specifically detects invasive
tumor
both of these applications use a virtual
double staining method where an
accurate tumor outline is obtained based
on the information in a serial tissue
section that has been
stained with a tumor marker
after having detected a relevant tumor
you can use ikea 67 app to quantify
positive and negative cells within the
tumor regions
finally if desired you can use our
hotspot app to find the hotspot in your
samples
so that's the solutions we offer for
diagnostic purposes
now on the research side of things we
offer an ai
and deep learning based approach so here
we have a tumor detection application
that consists of a pre-trained deep
neural network that detects
tumor based and tissue morphology the
method does not require any additional
tissue section but detects
tumors straight in your biomarker slide
and is therefore easy to apply
then we also have a ks67 solution based
on aei
this one can then go in and find
positive and negative nuclei
and you can combine all of this with a
hotspot app as well
so what i want to show you is how our
invasive tumor detection
combined with the care 67 app and
combined with the hotspot app gives a
fully automated ks67 assessment
so what we need to be able to conduct
such an analysis is that we need to have
some
breast cancer tissues stained for ks67
this is what we see here
but i may also need to have a cereal
section that has been stained with p63
and a cytokeratin
so what the p63 and cytokeratin stained
section allows us to do is that we can
go in and pinpoint what is invasive
tumor
and what is non-invasive and this we can
do
based on the p63 positive myoepithelial
cells that we see
in some structures we can then run
our invasive two-minute section app on
this image and we get the following
result
so here we have outlined the invasive
tumors in blue
and the non-invasive ones in orange
because this section is serial to our
case 67 section we can easily transpose
these
regions onto a ks67 slide
the next thing we then can do is that we
can go in and assess
how many ks67 positive and negative
nuclide we have
present for this we use ikea 67 app
[Music]
so here you can see how our app
very nicely outlines both the negative
and the positive nuclei
within the invasive tumor only
if we look at the results in the top
left corner
we can see that on this tissue slide we
actually analyze
a total of 175 1220
nuclei and i think that would have been
very difficult to do
manually but this is something we can
easily do with image analysis
we can also see that the proliferation
index
the global proliferation index for this
slide is 1.9
now apart from just doing a global
calculus scoring we can also do
a hotspot ks67 scoring
and to do a hotspot k67 scoring we use
our hotspot app that firstly goes in
and creates a heat map that shows us
where the highest concentration of
positive care 67 cells are
we can see that we have some action in
the
bottom right corner and in the top left
corner
based on this we can then place a
hotspot
so here we have decided to place a
hotspot that fits with a 20x microscope
field of view
but since there is no consensus on how a
hot spot should look like
we have developed the app so that you
can create the hotspot definition you
find most appropriate
if we look at the results we see that
the hotspot has the proliferation index
of
5.3 percent whereas the global score was
of
1.9
now our applications have been on the
market for quite some time
and for us to see in my them for in
virtual diagnostic use in europe we of
course had to do
a lot of validation tests to show that
they can actually perform adequately
since they have been on the market for
some years it also means that several
hospitals are using them and we also
have
some people that have actually published
articles based on what they have found
using
a ikea 67 app so
i would like to go back to the slideshow
and
show you a bit of scientific validity
when it comes to the ks67 application
so here we have an article by stool
hammer
and colleagues that was published in
modern pathology back in 2016.
and in the article they described a
study where they used
primary breast cancer specimens and had
a total of 436 samples
they also had 28 years of survival data
and then they scored all of these
samples for
ks67 er pr and her2
and the scoring was conducted manually
and also by digital image analysis by
using the solutions that we provide
so the manual and digital image analysis
results were compared for sensitivity
and specificity
for luminal b subtype for concordance to
pan 50 essays
and for prognostic power and in the
article
they conclude that the visual farm
digital image analysis
that they evaluated was in most aspects
a superior alternative to manual
biomarker scoring
they also say that it has the potential
to reduce time consumption for
pathologists
as many of the steps in the workflow are
either automatic or feasible to manage
without pathological expertise
another article published by the group
examined the value of
digital image analysis for kn67
including hotspot analysis
with the manual assessment against pam
50 gene expression
in this article and in the study they
had almost 300 patients
with up to 15 years of survival data and
what they concluded is that
image analysis of ki-67 was superior to
manual care kl67
and phh3 evaluations as well as to
mitotic counts in terms of separation of
patients with poor versus relatively
good survival
and they also say the digital image
analysis of ks67 in hotspots is the
marker of
choice for routine analysis of
proliferation in breast cancer
and a third article that i want to
highlight which is
conducted by another group it's by
koopman
and colleagues uh here they
used cereal whole tissue sections of 154
invasive breast carcinomas that were
staying in bkr67
and ck 8 and 18. what they did was that
they
manually assessed the ks67 proliferation
links
and then they also used two different
digital image analysis platforms
where one of the platforms is our base
platform
and they conclude that digital image
analysis using virtual double staining
is an accurate method to determine the
kcc7 proliferation index in breast
cancer
as an alternative to manual scoring of
whole tissue sections in clinical
practice
so i think that these articles very
nicely show
that using our care 67
workflows really can help you
standardize your ks67 assessment in the
laboratory
here in the end i want to show you how
our research use ki67 ai based
applications work
so here we have the same image that i
showed before
but only now i only have the ks67 stain
section
and not a p63 and tumor stained
section and this is because when we use
our ai based tumor detection application
we can detect the tumor straight in the
biomarker slide
and we don't need an extra serial
section
so this is the result of our ai
tumor detection application you can see
that it very neatly outlines
all the tumor that's present on this
slide
what we can do from here is that we can
run our ai-based ks67
app
what i would like you to notice here is
how the ai-based care 67 app
is better at mimicking the true shape of
a nuclei
this is because our ai app has learned
what a new client looks like
and it can apply this knowledge onto
this tissue piece as well
so with ai detection you can see that we
get a more
precise detection of both the tumor
contours
but also of what is a nuclei and what is
not
since we also have a researchers only
version of our hotspot app
we can actually also do hotspot
detection on this
image so this was all i have planned for
this session and i hope that you got a
good overview
of how digital pathology can help you
automate and standardize
your assessments so that you can get
precise and validated test results in
the clinic
thank you very much
so i'd like to thank junita one more
time for her excellent presentation
and i've enjoyed being your moderator
for this lecture if you have any
questions please feel free to ask us at
webinars at viziofarm.com
if you're interested in more in digital
pathology please feel free to visit
visio farms booth in the virtual
exhibition hall
thanks again for joining us and have a
great day